troubling new sign America is losing
right now in its fight against the
coronavirus we hate to lose the US has
surpassed 50,000 cases in a single day
for the first time it's the highest
daily number since his pandemic began
California had the most new cases with
nearly 10,000 followed by Texas and
Florida we have correspondents in all
three of those states we begin with
Carter Evans in Santa Monica California
Carter what's being done to stop this
well Anthony they're shutting things
down they essentially want the Santa
Monica Pier to look this weekend like it
does right now completely empty they've
already cancelled fireworks shows
they're closing the beaches and now the
governor is closing indoor operations at
many businesses for the next three weeks
we were able to bend the curve in the
state of California we're gonna bend
this curve again California's governor
Gavin Newsom is shutting down indoor
service at bars restaurants wineries and
movie theaters in 19 of California's 58
counties affecting nearly three-quarters
of the state's forty million residents
in the last two weeks coronavirus cases
in California are up more than 48
percent and statewide hospitalizations
are up more than 50 percent and the
University of Southern California
announced most fall undergraduate
classes will be conducted online
affecting more than 20,000 students at
least 18 states have now paused or
rolled back reopening plans including
New York which is delaying the return of
indoor dining in New York City in
response to outbreaks across the country
indoors is the problem or more the
science is showing it more and more
accelerating cases in Arizona prompted a
visit from Vice President Mike Pence
seen here wearing a mask we wanted to be
here to get a report from the ground
kovat related deaths and
hospitalizations in Arizona hit all-time
highs Wednesday with a record of more
than 4,800 new coronavirus cases and the
virus is tearing apart the families of
people like Leslie Lopez they should
have never reopened knowing that there's
still a pandemic going on
Lopez lost her husband Basilio Laster
day she says at one point his fever got
as high as 108 degrees I told them when
you get home I'm gonna buy you a really
nice cold to be here and he nodded yes
and then um and then I just broke my
heart because then he started crying and
we just all started crying and that was
the last time that we actually talked to
him I saw him vasilia Lopez had five
children and one grandchild they don't
know how he got the virus but his family
is pleading with people to follow Public
Health guidelines if not for your own
safety then for the safety of others in
your community
Tony it's a reminder there Carter of
what's at stake thank you very much